haha the Joe Rogan experience you just
watched it like quickly flip through it
and then um and then watch big cats big
cat or cakung what is that holy [ __ ] Joe
what is it
this is talk about faux confidence it's
a it's on Netflix and it might be the
most amazing show I've ever seen it's
about people who own big cats like
tigers and but the whole thing is about
about petting Cubs cub petting no no so
these guys make a living off cobb
petting so they bring the Cubs around
every once car and then what happens is
the Cubs grow up and then they end up
with big [ __ ] cats right and it is I
won't talk to you about it I'll let you
watch it and enjoy it with someone who's
like once you've seen it there's no
reason for me to tell you about it and
even if you treat your cat really really
well you got him in a cage the cat does
not want to be in a [ __ ] cage no [ __ ]
they don't want to be in a CodeRed
someone ripped off Brenda's arm it is
someone ripped off someone's arm Joe you
got to watch it it is it's a hundred and
eighty-seven cats on his oklahoma
property oh I'm gonna save it for when
you watch it and then we can rip
someone's arm off she went back to work
seven days my god no [ __ ] arm so she
now she has a stump little stump
oh my god still working with Big Easy
that is so crazy
can you imagine if they just started
eating part of you and you're like I
still got in a leg I get this part of my
foot the one guy found the job off
Craigslist do you think I never seen
anything like this [ __ ] it if you had a
job like that people are gonna sign up
like no matter what it is oh you've got
a job to go out and castrate wolfs
there's gonna be guys who like I think I
can do it oh by the way we haven't even
gotten to the [ __ ] crit this is not
even the crazy part when you get into
these guys lifestyles this guy married
one the first was get I look gay married
one dude and then they brought in
another dude they have a throuple that's
not the crazy one the crazy ones a guy
that lives in South Carolina that's got
[ __ ] nine wives
who he
goom's so this is what like look
everyone my special hey big boys on
Netflix but [ __ ] watch this show
first wow that's strong praise it is
Tiger king I'm writing that down I'm
putting it on my phone me and the girls
me the girls watched hey big boy and we
[ __ ] it was funny we giggled we've
talked through whatever like the at the
end credits I put like all the stuff
that's from the put Isles period party
cake I put the UM
I put in two credits I put like her test
my dad howling like an owl and and then
big cats comes along big king what's a
girl tiger King Tiger King that it and
with in 15 seconds George and I are like
alright everyone's up where we found our
show it's [ __ ] good it's good there's
something about people and giant crazy
animals people that want to keep those
animals as pets like there's this
Russian dude I think who has a polar
bear and he swims at the polar bear have
you ever seen it
no no there's a swimming pool with a
polar bear he's like hanging out with a
thing in cuddling with it I was like
what in the [ __ ] are you doing but you
don't identify with that a little bit
cuz I do I definitely do as a doob with
big dogs but I think it's cool you know
to watch cuz it's not killing him you
know it's like lookit it's hugging him
it's kissing him and to look like vibes
not well I think if you keep bears I
think are a different animal because if
you keep bears really well fed they
don't they're not just predators they're
omnivores right so if you keep bears
really well-fed they're probably pretty
chill and I wonder if bears are like
people like I think if you feed people
only vegetables I really believe this
they'd probably get less aggressive
because I think your body probably
doesn't think you need to be chasing
things and killing things because you're
not eating animal protein so everybody's
like oh we could just relax and stroll
just pick berries and eat grasses and
stuff you know what I think if you did
the same thing to a bear maybe if you
just gave the bay like apple pies and
yeah bro he's so big I would love I mean
like here's the problem is I would love
one yeah I don't think you're allowed to
have one for a real good reason because
people that should have [ __ ] dogs man
you've seen bad dogs and people have bad
dogs I there's a lot of people shouldn't
have dog special in LA yeah well there's
a lot of people that like don't they
don't train their dogs well and their
dogs are like really aggressive and they
they jump up on people you know
imaginative as a bear that did that just
a responsibility look at the length of
its neck so crazy they have such long
necks but the just what it is it's it's
you know the the animal that it is it
seems ridiculous you should be able to
have that in your backyard that's a
polar bear that guy wears that say oh
it's gotta be Ohio Oklahoma one of those
cities Ohio's one guy who shot himself
and let all the animals out yeah they
talk about that on the [ __ ] thing
that's part of the reason that it's
illegal to have a [ __ ] big heads in
Ohio
[Applause]